de la la busca to see this one here
anyway how's the shoulder blade too but
Phil here's a scrap of clothing hey its
that looks like a real good and useless
Abdullah neck which was didn't see
foreigners not many Bulgarians tried to
cross the border no would have called
Agatha's guises this is an arm bone but
I got for our cocktail Mila's play viola
back then they said a man and a woman
from East Germany came through this
ravine they set out from pomp orava and
walked all night through the mountain so
cell phone photo you know as a book on a
day approached the surveillance system
from this direction you know the other
year we said yo that triggered a signal
how could I gather and the border patrol
found them right here you can also order
idiot this was a platoon now gotta no
problem took it is apple picking the man
and the woman ran up that hill berita
the soldiers fired a warning shot but
the couple kept running so they were
liquidated you know they were German
that's the story I heard hold on your
months the thigh story has none so she
wouldn't
we're in the Rada p mountains of
southern Bulgaria paid up at can ski
shows us what's left of an old border
fence that once separated Vulgaria from
greece this area was off-limits a no
man's land is it possible that two East
Germans were shot here while trying to
flee to the West but Gonski says yes he
was a border guard here in the 1980s
he's legit then moved in me the soldiers
who were here back then I think they
were brainwashed to make them do that
kind of thing to shoot people pramod
music what some 02 / linea so the
brought that you were all the officers
who were in charge of political work
frost oil well they always hammered away
at the cars first you shoot to kill but
then you give a warning shot portals
young still he still asleep though but
it already told you we want to find out
more about the border and all the people
who died trying to cross it
Sofia this is where the country's
communist-era Secret Service archive is
located bulgaria only began ranting
access to the files a few years ago
here in the central state archive we
find evidence that many East Germans saw
the border between Bulgaria and Greece
as an opportunity to flee to the west
the Bluetooth of of gether able actually
build this cat the granite sir people in
East Germany mistakenly believed the
Bulgarian border wasn't a secure I've
found documents that say that more than
3000 East Germans mainly young people
tried to flee across the Bulgarian
border into the west between 1961 and
1989 the preeminent ott bulgaria naza
pedraza instructional gear Marcy we're
shown one document that confirms that in
1974 bulgaria and east germany agreed to
collaborate to prevent escapes to the
west at that time attempts to escape
across Bulgaria's border were thorn in
the side of East Germany the East German
leader Irish Monica had decreed that
anyone caught violating the border was
to be arrested or eliminated the regime
asked the Bulgarian government to follow
its lead
we returned to the border near you knock
to the tree decorated with bones we now
believe their human remains but who were
they are these truly the remnants of
East Germans killed while attempting to
flee or is it just a fanciful story a
sinister legend
there are more human remains under this
layer of leaves they show traces of
having been nailed to the tree we spend
just an hour in the area what might a
team of experts find here if they
conducted a thorough search we know that
in the 1960s there were cases of East
Germans who had been shot and buried
right at the Bulgarian border later in
the 1970s the two countries agreed that
the bodies of East German citizens who
had been shot would be buried in
cemeteries or returned to East Germany
we want to find out still more so we
decide to return to Germany we check
with the authorities to make sure that
taking the bones out of the country is
legal and are told these are unusual
circumstances and there's nothing in
Bulgarian law that would prevent it we
bring the bones to the University of
Munich for analysis Peter Horne forensic
anthropologist guess is that a possible
date of death would be 1977 bhagat sighs
yeah pawn and his colleague Christina
Lane will use geochemical analysis to
try to determine what country the victim
might have come from the collagen in
human bones can tell us a lot what
climate a person lived in what his diet
consisted of and what environmental
factor is he might have experienced
the results are compared to samples from
around the world that way the bones can
be identified according to their
geographical region but the two
scientists come to differing conclusions
Pater horn believes that traces of lead
indicate they come from northeastern
Germany Christina Lane thinks dietary
evidence shows the originated from the
Balkans the results are inconclusive and
our question remains unanswered back
then incidents involving East German
citizens at the Bulgarian border were
reported to authorities in East Berlin
so we set out in search of evidence that
might confirm the story told by pay
dapat can ski the former Bulgarian
border guard the intelligence services
of the two countries collaborated
closely Bulgaria's border was part of
the Iron Curtain we combed through old
Stasi files in the archives of the
former East German intelligence service
we're searching for evidence of a young
man and woman killed at the Bulgarian
Greek border sometime in the 1970s we
find countless files documenting arrests
some describe incidents in which the
would-be escapees were injured sometimes
badly there are also a few reports about
East Germans who were shot in Bulgaria
but only one file matches the story told
to us by pet can ski an excerpt reads
operative information on 13 August 1974
at about three-thirty am the East German
citizens from Gustav ski Brigitta and
proach Klaus were shot by Bulgarian
border guards near the Greek border
the young couple were both in their 20s
they went to Bulgaria on holiday whether
they'd planned an escape attempt from
the outside is unknown but we do know
that most who tried to escape were
arrested only a few made it to the west
in Leipzig we meet one of classes old
co-workers back in the summer of
nineteen seventy five Stefan benkert
brigita funk Ostrovsky and Klaus pouch
went on holiday together your voice oh
gosh stop the unstop this is where we
started our motorcycles were parked on
the street then we headed towards
Budapest but we didn't make it that far
so we spent the first night in
Czechoslovakia lofted then they headed
towards the Black Sea he's played us I
didn't notice I wish I'd taken more
pictures of him over.more Klaus alive
and well Klaus smiling he had an impish
smile for from its legend oh poor kid
and play get her and she was a lovely
girl y'all trainers neither does us this
was taken in the rila mountains here's a
real a monastery at the campground
that's where we spent the last night mog
remains we SAT around the campfire and
had drinks with some other campers and
guess people from West Germany East
Germany it was a real mix and everyone
had a good time the next day Stefan
benkert took off on his own shoppin Isis
when I got back to work one of my
colleagues told me I would never see
Klaus and decatur again he said they'd
been killed in a traffic accident in
slavery comes in
that was a lie
our search brings us back to the Rada p
mountain region and the small town of
Barrino about 15 kilometers from the
Greek border we meet the forest ranger
who'd given the young couple a place to
stay the night dominica that was a long
time ago emerging Foreign Legion I
remember but it gets her better than
Klaus very good love morbid slit my
pajamas another man we spoke about the
area no bogus man and about how far we
were away from the Greek border ok the
logical method to talk of a silk alot of
the diet demo and how far it was to the
spa town of pamporovo well don't never
gotten a bad idea yeah I had a map of
Bulgaria No No Go Go the Luger we got it
out and we looked to see how far it was
to pamporovo go see under smooth good
took degrees Ian the latest yeni
thinnest of them but we never thought
they were planning to escape ah missile
in destin ugh we did it but there is
village Dame at the marina we enjoyed
ourselves we drank just like we would
with any guests bus ticket to boston
until about two or 230 in the morning no
giddy goons his buddies augustana birth
babe do you know a puzzle they said they
would head for pamporovo the next
morning and stay there the next night so
then it doesn't sit amid this but they
slept in the bed room we stayed in the
guest room
let's do glitter the next evening post
them and I got home from work my wife
said to me no Germans have been killed
but what really happened back then on an
internet forum we read that some former
border guards are planning a meeting at
the eunuch border outpost the men get
together for an outing every year it's a
coincidence that they're meeting now
while we are here doing research
the road to their old border outpost is
rough and winding these men were guards
here during the 1980s just like pet a
pet can ski who showed us the tree with
the bones but bet can ski is not here
now one member of the group is ilya bull
chef he was a lieutenant colonel in the
guard unit this is where we used to sit
there's the fireplace back then this
outpost had about 30 or 35 soldiers the
Cold War was ever-present the guards
protected the border of the Warsaw Pact
nations against NATO after the fall of
communism the outpost was abandoned we
still haven't told them that we took the
bones from the nearby tree
[ __ ] quarters this is a log book we
used to keep we recorded who was on duty
and what they did if anything happened
while they were on duty even teleport
we're planning a boo boo and exhausted
which is the lighter bria towards a
man's best friends this is where the
dogs are kept as I was a dog handler
here I'm a Greenwich as the men assemble
for a group picture we decided to tell
them how their colleague paid a pittance
key brought us here how he showed us the
tree with the bones and how we took some
of the bones with us the men are
surprised and displeased we tell them
about the Munich analysis which
determined that bones came from the
Balkans or maybe East Germany but the
former commander disagrees that you
would it I'll explain it to you exactly
the way it was and I won't call on the
opinions of some professors but on the
history of this border outpost no German
citizen was ever killed here at the
border that's the truth what bet can ski
told you is just something he made up
the men take us along their old border
patrol route back in the 1980s they
patrolled six kilometers of the border
to Greece
yeah I can never learn it evolved Utley
he sacado tastes were numbers mr.
quality in approach are stuck when the
alarm was triggered national the exact
location the post number holy in our log
book document our chica de la Mer
initial love it there what I didn't all
right this here was 57 please see them
most of the men are not interested in
stopping at the tree they're not happy
that we removed the bones for the border
guards the beech tree was a symbol
identical yeah for my fellow can see the
shape of a bone it's too bad they aren't
here
during the Cold War anyone trying to
escape would have encountered this
barbed wire fence which they climbed
over cut through or dug their way
underneath after getting past the fence
they assumed they were safe in Greece
but in truth they were still in Bulgaria
activity at the fence set off an alarm
alerting the Border Patrol the actual
border was still 1,500 metres away the
strip between was a no man's land which
gave the Border Patrol plenty of time to
catch up with the would-be escapees
manisha theme aboot anoche a propaganda
film in the 1980s says they're ready and
alert at the border when they sound the
alarm the soldiers take their positions
within minutes
the film was used to recruit young
soldiers for the guard units the
soldiers were conscripts between 18 and
22 years of age
you
we accompany the men along the entire
six kilometre route you live will Jeff
promises to tell us the truth about the
bones at the end of our march the
question stickam and now I'll tell you
about the bone when they started
building the surveillance system when
they used a bulldozer in the ravine
where the birch tree is located Brian
when the bulldozers started digging it
hit a bunch of bones what what that's
for linear Youngstown there must have
been a cemetery here in bill rubbish
nubuck they got biscuits other we
collect the bones and put them next to a
birch tree look money it's a good
question Ned no man and the soldiers
were supposed to Ribery the bones but
they buried them near the surface not
too deep sir zakupy Genuity but not
bunny so eventually the bones reappeared
on the ground and then they were nailed
onto the tree the waters that's where
the lawns ktf was G is a post on in the
buca Claire's a question to the next day
when the cameras weren't running some of
the men told us a different story and
they said that vu jeff had always
claimed the bones belonged to East
Germans who had been shot
you
the village of chip in Z is not far from
the border outpost back then the village
was in the restricted area anyone who
wanted to get near the border zone
needed a permit so no one knows anything
about a cemetery in the forest in those
days people who lived in the restricted
area were supposed to help monitor the
border it was their duty to report any
Outsiders in the area to the Border
Patrol's the border cast a heavy shadow
over the region anyone who balked at
following the rules was forced to move
somewhere else Roger a menacing off grew
up here in this wooded border region on
the other side was the enemy NATO even
as children our lives were tied up with
the border okeus Granite's the communist
regimes propaganda was very effective
overall octopus obscure to zoom in the
spring they used to bring groups of
children to the border outpost and give
them rakes DQ we had to rake a strip of
land two or three metres wide battery
metha hablar so we raked the ground so
that footprints would be visible if
anyone came near the fence we also saw
the birch tree with the bones nailed on
it most of it was pretty scary we were
just kids you know one of the soldiers
told us that the bones belong to someone
who had tried to escape he had been shot
and they nailed him to the tree to
frighten anyone else who might be
planning to escape
what is the truth behind the bones found
at eunuch we sent samples of them to
Mannheim for further testing how old are
the bones exactly brant coma conducted
the test in one of the ironies of
history a Cold War legacy can help
provide an answer the hydrogen bomb
tests carried out above ground by the
Soviet Union in the United States left
behind traces that can be detected in
human bones they're used for radiocarbon
dating in what's called the bomb peek
method London's a fencing aha we
measured the carbon-14 content of the
bones and the bones do contain carbon 14
from bombs or what we call bomb c14
that's carbon-14 that entered the
atmosphere via these above-ground bomb
tests the tests were primarily carried
out between 1955 in 1962 so these
persons must have been alive during that
time which is when the carbon-14 would
have been absorbed by their bones so
these bones can't be that old meaning
they can't predate 1950
so the bones are definitely not hundreds
of years old as the former Border
commander claimed we still haven't given
up hope of finding an answer
we return to retrace the steps of Klaus
in boogita back in august 1975 the two
East Germans approached the Greek border
through this ravine they were pursued by
300 Bulgarian border guards all
searching for the two East Germans the
search began in the evening and ended
towards dawn we meet someone who was
there that night in August the yoga guru
cough was part of the search unit he
still remembers the dramatic events if
they compiled they dug their way
underneath the surveillance system under
the wire this is the border to Greece r
is the distance from the surveillance
system to the actual border was about
one or one and a half kilometers once
the pair had got past the fence and into
the border strip they started walking at
east side instead of south but the
surveillance system didn't run in a
straight line its curve so as they walk
they ran into it again they got past it
a second time and that's when we picked
up that trace they'll really good border
patrol found Klaus and Brigitte are
sitting on a really big Bush was an
officer from the Border Patrol a man
named ms off what more diva he was
afraid that they might flee across the
border chamari the syllables as the
officer in charge of the border unit he
would have been severely punished the
corner so he did what he considered the
heroic thing the guy who missed us he
opened fire on Klaus and Brigitte an
original post op k e grill proof strobe
oppo Klaus
oh Lola a lot of shots were fired it
took two or three minutes it's as though
they were shooting at an entire gang of
criminals it was completely abnormal the
whole thing was horrible it's just a
dusty start our research leads us to
another intelligence report Klaus and
Brigitte ax were nowhere near the birch
tree when they were shot but the report
includes a surprising detail they were
shut on greek soil what happened an
excerpt tells us at roughly 4 30 a.m. on
thirteen august 1975 the Border Patrol
found the border crossers between the
border posts 220 and 221 they were told
to halt into surrender but they ran
south deeper into Greek territory they
were pursued caught and liquidated then
their bodies were carrying back onto our
territory it is to be assumed that Greek
citizens and authorities will disclose
this mission because 1 140 bullets were
fired from a Kalashnikov and not all the
casings were collected to the blood was
not collected and buried three the
woman's shoes remained in Greece
Mustafa army chef the forest ranger who
had given Klaus and Brigitte to a place
to stay for the night was called in to
identify their bodies the border guards
had found his address among closest
things
Ledford we took were spittle that's what
the man who killed them told me modulate
second lieutenant amazon when
derivational he was the deputy commander
of the border post snagless let very
much mr. slits but the Masonic I saw him
again two or three months later in
Barrino it it's just got a divot suit
laureate ago I asked him there is we
felt after killing those people Cobra
the Red dig'em thank seduces let go to
dear know what it imagine a they become
the girls to it I asked him why he
didn't just arrest them instead of
shooting them the gear estrela to it
well I he said so awesome girl I
followed them all night and I've had it
up to here I would have shot anyone at
that moment you know you know Stig no
Krieger I caught up with them a dog suit
winter please pretty this video did I
say vehicle could agree director sir hmm
um jeito the young man tried to pull out
a knife boom is good I myself thought it
was a gun still at least we could just
love Watkiss few more he said I shot and
I split his head into journey foul [ __ ]
cell phone work there's a woman was
sitting alegna we just thought the
priest amaretto I think she must have
been resting the woman brigita she was
shocked us would pose no it was a bun
she stood up and raised her hands in the
air she said Elizabeth friends eat esta
vida guerra sitter roozbeh you can a
mother than Emma's offset no friends and
empty three magazines in her Stefan was
taking a good the bodies were taken to
Sofia where they were autopsy and buried
the bones could not have belonged to
Bridget and cloths but their story may
well have become part of the legend
surrounding the tree Amos off the one
who fired the shots can't tell his side
of the story he has since died clauses
and bridget is bodies were later exuma
and returned to East Germany after
pressure from their families still in
Berlin we meet will get his sister
Buddha Schaeffer we show her a copy of
the official report from the Bulgarian
archive an entire look at the site this
is a Bristol certainty they just refer
to liquidation as if it were nothing
that was their intention their aim and
that's exactly what they did wondered
felt sick but 140 bullets for two people
does hurt Angus nuts and so on one night
our doorbell rang it was about midnight
or something like that there was a man
and a woman at our door and they
insisted on speaking to my mother they
said my sister and Klaus had died in a
road accident has come octa in formats
yawn but my mother was also told that
they'd tried to escape across the border
and had been shot that was what we knew
but we weren't allowed to tell anyone
we do from kind of taller fire we
weren't allowed to have a funeral dorfa
meetings only the immediate family was
permitted at the burial so the only
chance we had to say goodbye to my
sister was the open grave where they'd
already put the metal coffin we got
seeing socks on hang up girl Ozma then
my family had a few minutes there at the
grave and then we had to leave Parma
Newton kidding that was it when almost
got a bit again that's why I English
others it was a cover up the East German
police lied to everyone finding out what
really happened was impossible and it
still is to this day even now local
residents are reluctant to talk about
what happened are they afraid of the
past
in the meantime we're convinced the
bones must belong to people who tried to
escape but who were they we follow a tip
given to us by one of the border guards
and go to the town of Kirsten deer in
western Bulgaria we want to pay a visit
to met toadies lychkoff on the phone he
said he knew who the bones belonged to
miss Goff served in eunuch from nineteen
sixty three to nineteen seventy-four and
held the rank of sergeant he was there
when three escapees were shot he didn't
fire himself but he was part of a unit
of six soldiers the three would be
escapees were already in no man's land
the strip between the signal fence and
the Greek border mrs. Chu Synthesia said
the bit that we do yeah it must have
been the fall of 1965 did he man three
people tried to cross the border
muskegon isn't it they were bulgarian
citizens they got past the surveillance
system and ran toward the border though
do not that is Viva when the border unit
arrived they set off in pursuit I mean
of the guys a little while later they
caught up with the three-man then told
him to stop and surrender the best
evidence that these vessels that I met
bet she is this tegan the border guards
fired some warning shots into the air a
little bit at least a leave of us look
there's three month so this not the
three-man kept running in different
directions toward the border vision
Ashley getting exciting our border
guards were afraid that they wouldn't be
able to catch them the moment the east
and they'd make it into neighboring
territories little shitty the permanent
necessarily datoria nos llegan HR
assistant so they felt they had no
choice but to shoot you get video
and they liquidated them on the spot
they buried them said he's visibly but
at some point foxes dug up your bones is
that it costs it did this is equally but
let me say again those are not the bones
of German citizens that is certain they
belong to Bulgarians who tried to cross
the border that is definite guys get the
goodies was a notorious Cove gave us
some useful information we're looking
for three Bulgarians who were shot in
unit probably around 1965 to find out
more we head for 2 different archives
the Sofia archive and the military
archive in veliko tarnovo which contains
many of the official documents relating
to the border and its history
we search for information about that
particular section of the border and the
Bulgarians who were killed there we want
to compare the official files with what
metodi / cough told us in the records we
find only one case that matches his
story of the three Bulgarian men who
were shot but it occurred three years
later in 1968 the three men were from
the village of irani Luke in western
Bulgaria 800 people lived here in the
1960s today there are just 20 we ask
some questions but the villagers seem
reluctant maybe even afraid to discuss
what happened almost 50 years ago one
old man is willing to speak with us but
he doesn't want to show his face on
camera doko betcha Terrell area it was a
tragedy some people wept maybe others
refused to believe it I agree but then
it was made official Rosslyn America
Tristan they posted a notice about the
people they called traitors let be here
and we had to accept that it was true
well he's managed than a roadie no
thought the notice was posted in all the
villages as a deterrent we've seen it
said the traitors received a cruel
punishment what does hello they posted
pictures of them and their names oh he's
managed to demand that they came from
the village of Ronnie looking at Ron
pushed him he did sneaky Baker zealot
Billy my data I was sick for weeks for
months hotel or running their own school
yeah yes beg God I couldn't believe what
had happened said me that our three boys
friends had died such an unnatural death
dream of death among jet on a few
prettily forgot it
see they were shot like dogs at the
border murphy's BTW cut the couch Utley
Megaton it he also provides us with some
information about the victims families
the names of brothers of each of the
three men who were killed finding them
isn't easy they've all since changed
their names but they tell us the three
young men were friends they were young
and wanted to escape to the other side
of the Iron Curtain they didn't tell
anyone of their plan Maricopa Jeff's
brother was 27 when he was shocked at
the border Oh bull bleep in the hooch he
was quick witted whistle he found a
solution to every problem was she
doesn't that he was smarter than me no
matter what it was about work money
whatever he always found a way that mean
I'm not you you know she wanted cichlid
he had a motorcycle Oh she'll never look
he gave it to me well as long as he told
me he was going to the coast
yash there it's missus damita sock off
still doesn't know where his brother is
buried Ashley Adnan commercial on the
day we got the news from the militia
they came to us and told us they had
been killed at the broader chest we
drove with my brother-in-law to small
Jana we met with the district attorney
he told us they had been shot attempting
to escape across the border or corona
papa ron just to go three sentences yes
and then we were told to leave to say
he's big I got into these galleys of the
pnina he something wanted to go to where
it happened and see them and claim their
bodies for burial didn't miss ball those
even the UV didn't they give his enemy
though seen a brand new but they
wouldn't let us do that budget when the
nearest ship we can oppose valentia
Guido so about the ghoul Mme breath my
oldest brother called a bludgeon a
little tight he was crying it would be
too sir he told me that our brother
Gregor and two others had been shot at
the border what a nice propulsion is
done he didn't get any official notice
the people in the village told him that
the war is immaculate and Nikoli not
awesome personally Nikki my brother
drove to the border administration and
Tron and asked what had happened beneath
a eve of their man Bishop rotten and
Linda do you talk you of them he asked
for the official report but honest a
lotta yeah Peter the that's what he
malooley I told him there wasn't working
Nana India tonight so we thought my
brother was still alive but teaches key
issue Luca virtual to acquit we looked
for him through the red cross through
the party newspaper the interior
ministry
the Bulgarian news agency the State
Council but the only such a bishop visa
on our applications we wanted to know
the truth there was a lustre movement
even today we still don't know the truth
mughal demolition is through the veneers
their tests conclude that the DNA of the
three young Bulgarians who were shot
does not match that of the bones founded
the tree in eunuch many documents at the
intelligence archive in Sofia have been
destroyed and so the history of the
border is incomplete in the files that
are left there is no other incident that
matches what we're searching for and so
our journey comes to an end we can't
give a name to the victims but we know
that the remains of the three young
Bulgarians are somewhere in the forest
as are many others the dead in the
forest near eunuch do not rest in peace
Oh